- [Instructor] We're
going to do in this video
is have an overview of one
of the greatest empires
and really civilizations of
not only the ancient world,
but of the world, and that is Persia.
And we see a map here, this
is the extent of the Persian
empire at around 500 B.C.E.
under Darius the Great
and in future videos we'll
talk more about Cyrus the Great
and Darius the Great and
the various Shah and Shahs
King of Kings of the Persian
empire, but you can see
it was a massive empire.
Not only did it contain
modern Iran which is really
the heart of the Persian
empire, but much of the modern
Middle East including
Turkey, you have Egypt here
we go into central Asia
and also Afghanistan
and even parts of Pakistan.
But before talking more
about how it was established
and who established it, I'm
gonna dig down a little bit
into the word "Persia"
because just as the ancient
Greeks did not refer to
where they lived as Greece
that is a Latin idea of calling it Greece,
the Greeks referred to where
they lived as "Hellas",
it turns out that the
Persians did not refer
to where they lived as "Persia".
Their terms are actually
much closer to ideas around
land of the Aryans, so
there's, based on my research,
ideas like Aryan-Vega
and Aran-Shah and Aran.
So it actually turns out
that the modern name of the
country, the modern word Iran
is probably more appropriate
or in some ways closer to
what the region has always
called itself, what the
Iranians or the Persians have
always called themselves,
and called where they lived.
They referred to themselves
as the Aryans and where
they lived as the Aryanan-Vega
or Aran, or Aran-Shah
or some version of that and
the modern version is Iran.
Now, with that said, you might say,
"Well, why did the Greeks call it Persia?"
Well, the Persian empire what
we consider to be the first
true Persian empire is the
Achaemenid empire, and we'll
talk in a second why do we
call it even the Achaemenid,
but the Achaemenid empire
emerges from a region
of Persia, I guess we can
say, that in this map is
referred to as Persus,
but other names for it are
Pars, and even in modern
Iran there's a region called
Fars which coincides very close with it.
And since the leaders of the
Persian empire, and especially
Cyrus the Great, emerged from
this region, they called them
the Persians and it was the
"Persian" empire that emerges
from this region which you
might wanna call Pars, Fars.
Fars especially comes from
Arabic where they don't
have the P sound, but Pars or
Persus or whatever you wanna
call it, and that's why it
was called the Persian empire.
Now, it wasn't the first
empire in that region.
Before the Persian empire
gets established or what
we associate with the Persian
or the Achaemenid empire
of Cyrus the Great, much
of this region of where we
call modern day Iran was
controlled by the Medians,
and you can see Media is
this region right over here.
And it was Cyrus the Great
that in 549, some accounts
say 550 B.C.E., is able to
overthrow the Median emperor
who happens to be his grandfather.
And that is the really dawn
of the Achaemenid dynasty.
Now the next question
and this was established,
let me write this down, this
was established by Cyrus
the Great, he was Cyrus the II
but he became Cyrus the Great
because he was able to break
out and overthrow the Medians
and establish this massive empire.
And the reason why it's
called the Achaemenid empire
not the Cyrid empire, is
that Cyrus claims to be from
the family of the patriarch
Achaemenis and a lot of
these names, these are
come from Greek accounts so
that's why they sound a
little bit more Greek.
But Achaemenis is a semi-legendary
figure that, we're not
sure exactly when he lived,
but the best accounts I could
see is near the beginning of
the seventh century B.C.E.
And Cyrus the Great is
from Achaemenis' family,
and so since they came to
power, this first really Persian
empire, when the people talk
about the Persian empire
they don't tend to refer to
the Median empire, they're
really referring to the Achaemenid empire,
that's why it's called Achaemenid.
Now, in future videos we'll
talk more about what happened
in the Achaemenid empire, but
you can see the extent of it
was pretty significant and it
lasts for a little over 200
years until they're
conquered by foreigners.
And the foreigners that
conquer them are the Greeks.
Philip of Macedon's son,
Alexander the Great, is able to,
on some level, unify Greece and Persia.
And it's interesting because
a lot of what we learn about
ancient Persia, it's
accounts from the Greeks,
from folks like Herodotus,
but during the time
of classical Greece, Greece
was really a bit of a sideshow,
it was really this kind of
thorn in the side of Persia.
Persia was really where the power was.
But as we get to the mid or
the end of the fourth century
B.C.E., Persia weakens,
Greece unifies under Philip
of Macedon and Alexander the
Great and Alexander the Great
is able to conquer the Persian empire.
And he is short-lived, we have
videos on Alexander the Great
I encourage you to watch
them, his life is short-lived
and his unified empire is
short-lived, but he has this
dream of mixing the cultures
and really being a unified
people, but as soon as he
dies his empire splits,
but the Persian empire for the most part,
is in the control of the Seleucid's.
And the Seleucid dynasty, this
is essentially foreign rule
'cause Seleucus, who
establishes Seleucid dynasty,
he is one of Alexander's
generals, he's fundamentally
Greek, and so the rulers of
the Seleucid dynasty are Greek.
And you don't get back
to having Persian rule
until 238 B.C.E.
It's in 238 B.C.E. that the
Parthian's emerge to conquer
the empire and so, once
again you could say,
"Well, this is back to non-foreign rule."
It's really important
to keep in mind, because
in it's day the Achaemenid
empire was, if not the dominant,
one of the very dominant
empires of the world.
At it's peak it had a
population, this is roughly
under Darius the Great, and
we'll talk more about him,
he was an interesting
character, but the Achaemenid
empire at it's peak had
approximately 50 million people.
And that's a lot of people
at any time in history,
but especially at that time in history
because at that time in
history there was only
a little over 100 million
people in the world,
or at least that's our current estimates.
So this is actually the largest
proportion of the world's
population that any empire
has ever had in history,
as far as we can tell, so
that gives it some claim
to being maybe the greatest
or one of the greatest
empires in world history.
And then, as we get into
the Seleucid and especially
the Parthian empire, you
know, in the West we talk
a lot about the glory of the Roman empire,
but the Parthian's were right
there beside of them, and
they kind of went back and forth
but they were side by side,
the peak of the Parthian
empire coincides with the peak
of the Roman empire, and they
give each other space and
they went back and forth
especially around the Middle East.
And you have this empire
from the Parthian's you go to
the Sassanian's and eventually
in the seventh century C.E.,
Islam comes into the Persian empire
and becomes the dominant religion.
And so that might make you ask,
"Well, what was the dominant
religion before that?"
And the answer there is Zoroastrianism.
Zoroastrianism.
And it was really Cyrus
the Great, by establishing
the Persian empire, who
really spreads Zoroastrianism.
And Zoroastrianism is based
on their prophet Zarathustra.
And when Zarathustra lived is
up for some debate, it might
be as early as 1500 B.C.E.,
some people say it might
be even right before even
coincident with the life
of Cyrus the Great, so
there's some debate on when
Zarathustra lived, but it
was a monotheistic religion,
following the one god of Ahura Mazda.
Ahura Mazda.
And it was based on these
ideas of good thoughts lead
to good words and good deeds.
Other big ideas of the
Persian empire is their system
of governments, of governants.
Because it was such a
vast empire they delegated
the emperor, the Shah and
Shah, the King of Kings,
delegated authority to the
regions so each region,
each satrapy had it's
governor called a satrap.
And as we see over time, some
of these satraps got more
power then maybe was intended
and then eventually took over.
But this was a major empire
in the history of the world,
they unified people, they're
famous for royal road
that connected Sardis all the
way, all the way to Sousa,
as you can imagine it would
have facilitated the transfer
of knowledge and the transfer of trade.
Under the Seleucid's you
had huge Greek influence,
but it was two way street.
Not only did the Greeks
influence the Persians,
but the Persians heavily
influenced the Greeks.
So with that, in the next
few videos we'll go into
even more depth on the Persian empire
and specifically the Achaemenid's.